es ist der durchbruch darauf haben wir
lange gewartet das akku der superlative
ist speicher dreimal so viel energie wie
heute war groß und kann in einen achtung
paar minuten aufgeladen wer nachher
unter für sicher und geht nicht in
flammen auf utopie wunschtraum oder
fantasterei mitnichten und wie
funktioniert das ganze jetzt wicklung
science fiction und uhr herzlich
willkommen
also ich hab ich nicht schlecht gestaunt
als ich auf diese meldung der university
of texas gestoßen bin
der miterfinder des lithium-ionen-akkus
on good enough hat eine neue akku
technologie entwickelt die die herzen
aller smartphone nutzer und
elektroautofahrer höher schlagen wenn
diese technologie in der praxis
eingesetzt wird dann werden unsere
heutigen akku probleme der vergangenheit
angehören problem nummer eins akkus
halten den meisten geräten nicht mal
einen tag oder bei elektroautos kaum 100
km beides ist einfach unzureichend
fördert es immer besser aber das neue
akkus verspricht diesen engpass
endgültig zu beseitigen
es soll drei mal mehr energie speichern
als aktuelle akku smartphones würden so
zu bauer läufern und noch mitnehmen
danach noch genügend energie haben um
mal eben einen spielfilm anzusehen
elektroautos wie der opel ampera würden
mit einer akkuladung sogar mehr als 1000
kilometer weit kommen mehr als man an
einem tag fahren kann oder sollte und
dazu verlieren die neuen akkus bis zu
minus 60 grad celsius kaum kapazität das
heißt dass die reichweite auch bei
niedrigen temperaturen komsic wahnsinn
problem nummer zwei die ladezeiten ein
elektroauto zu machen kann heutzutage
schon mal einen tag oder sogar noch
länger dauern und west an
schnellladestationen dauert es
mindestens eine halbe stunde bis das
akku zu 80 prozent mit einem
herkömmlichen auto mit verbrennungsmotor
ist das immer noch verglichen immer noch
mindestens sechs mal länger die neuen
akkus soll in wenigen minuten geladen
sein und dabei auch noch deutlich
langlebiger sein
das ist auch für smartphones ein
riesenvorteil kurzwahl an die steckdose
und schon hat man wieder strom für einen
ganzen tag
problem nummer drei sicherheit es ist
gelöst die neue technologie verhindert
dass sich die akkus entzünden können die
lösung des problems an elektrolyten geht
keine flüssigkeit mehr sondern glas so
können
wie in der flüssigkeit keine den briten
also für fall bäume mehr von der anode
zur kathode wachsen und die zelle kurz
schließen außerdem besitzt glas auch
noch bei minus 20 grad celsius und sogar
noch bei minus 60 grad ehses eine
hervorragende leitfähigkeit wodurch die
kapazität kaum sinken ab geht davon aus
dass mit der neuen technologie endlich
elektroautos zum preis von benzinern
hergestellt werden können die neuen akku
sollen nämlich deutlich preiswerter als
aktuelle akku sein
jetzt müssen die akkus noch in den
handel kommen das wird allerdings noch
etwas dauern
allerdings wollen die forscher schon
bald erste elektroauto prototypen damit
testen ja und hier geht es zu einem
special zum thema elektroautos von der
form die ihn in berlin und hier könnte
mir noch ein abo aufs auge drücken und
mir dann auf jeden fall noch einen auf
die glocke geben also da oder da
draufklicken also bis dann bleibt